Hey guys. This is going to be a bit more of a serious vlog than I've done in the past, because as many of you know
and as many of you probably don't know, over this past weekend there was a series of tragedies and I won't go
into too many details, but they involved shootings and a lot of death and these are subjects that I don't normally
talk about on my channel and unfortunately they happen too often, and when they do, you guys often ask me
Y'know, to speak out about it, or try to tell you guys a way that we can prevent it or stop it from happening.
And I- I'm very hesitant to do those things because one, I'm not in any way qualified.
I do this channel because it's for entertainment and it's for you guys and those of you out there who enjoy
watching my videos, I know that I make videos to make you laugh and I know I make videos to give you guys
an escape from your daily lives. And when something like this, something so big that it affects so many people
and it kind of crosses barriers where it shouldn't cross barriers. I just want to say a few things and not even
specifically about the subject at hand. I want to say things to you guys on an individual level.
And I know that's hard because I am literally sitting in my bathroom talking to a camera that's going out to over a
million people, and it's really hard to make that connection on an individual level, but that's what
I want to do when I make these videos. That's what I really want to do when I make all of my videos.
And so the one thing that was standing out in my mind that I had to tell you guys is ;
I want you guys to be as good as you can be. And to be as connected as you can be to those around you,
because we as people, we can get together and we can make, y'know protests, we can march in the streets,
we can do whatever, we can make change, but when it comes down to the loneliness that you feel when
you're by yourself and you are feeling so isolated from the world and you see these things that happen and
You- you know that you feel you can't do anything about it and it's that feeling of helplessness that really
gets people down. And so I just want to tell you, as an individual, that the best thing that you could possibly do
is be as good as you possibly can, and be the best person that you can, and try to share that good
with those around you.
Because I'm not qualified to talk about how to solve these problems. I don't know the first thing about,
like, preventing these things from happening.
But this channel has always been about encouraging you as an individual, as a creator, as a person, as a friend,
as a member of your community, like, whatever you are;
Try to be the best that you possibly can be.
So that's all I wanted to say about it. I don't want to come across like I'm trying to make someone else's
tragedy about myself. Because that is the exact opposite of what I want, and that's never what I
would want to do. All I'm trying to say is that you, as an individual, you're never alone.
And you're never going to be alone, and whether that's good or bad, like literally, you're never going to be alone,
because what you do, and who you are, is always going to affect someone else in this world, like we're literally
all connected, and that's obviously a big "Kumbaya" statement that's all very happy-go-lucky statement,
but it's absolutely true, and it's more evident than ever in these situations. So just remember that the good that
you do, and the good that you bring to the world... It really does make a difference.
So thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always, I will see you in the next video.
Buh-bye.